vibrante et miro machine
[Applaudissements]
elle éclopés
vous dites aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu
une star
mais c'est quoi talent mon talent
actuelle oui bah je pense de fédérer
d'arriver à faire du business de faire
rire les gens
de mener des interviews sur des sujets
en faisant de vraies comment dire
devrait rechercher de vraies enquêtes
j'ai quand même je dirais pas démantelé
mais j'ai quand même révélé l'existence
d'un réseau de prostitution au sein de
la télé réalité en france donc il ya
tout un côté immersif donc je me suis
découvert finalement des talents quand
j'étais plus jeune je ne pensais pas les
avoir donc en fait voilà en étant self
made on se rend compte que j'ai bossé
comme un chien et je bosse des nuits
entières sur mes montages vidéo donc je
pense que le talent finalement c'est
peut-être le travail aussi
suite
18 cbl
je te tiens tu me tiens par la
barbichette clamait le premier de nous
deux qui rarement de larrazet est un qui
voit où tu étais un air demo tech est ce
que c'est que le ou la synthèse ou que
des grosses testicules avec à chaque
fois qu'il a fait
et tu sais au fond du lapin dans le
langage de sourds et malentendants n'ont
pas pas
[Rires]
du tout était
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]